Here's a list.
of
the concepts that we want to understand intuitively.
Because understanding them.
intuitively will make your
Journey
to learning regression analysis much easier
You see the syntax. There are two
issues again when it comes to learning.
statistics in general but specifically learning regression analysis
You have the syntax.
Like the mathematical notation. I just showed an example
where
one Greek letter is used to mean something.
Different something specific in hypothesis, testing what
in regression analysis that same letter is used to mean
something completely different.
one is the notation is the
the problem the second and I would
say bigger problem.
Is how these terms are defined?